I don't know who I think I am in
thinking that I can read 30 books in
three months,
but I'm gonna try.
Who gave me the permission to act this
delusional? I don't know. However,
somehow I've convinced myself that I can
read 30 books in the span of 3 months,
which realistically is not the most
delusional thing ever because I have
really I have really good reading months
where I'm reading 10 to 15 books in a
month. But that's also when it's like
summertime and I'm feeling a little less
seasonally depressed than I normally am.
Even though I am seasonally depressed
year round. But you know what? I am just
going to keep with the delusional trend
and I'm going to pretend like I will be
able to read all 30 plus of these books
in the next 3 months. And so I wanted to
walk you guys through my fall TBR so
that you can be delusional, too, and
start reading these books just like me.
Okay, before I get into this, if you
have read any of these, make sure to let
me know what you thought of them in the
comments so that I have a little bit
more to go off of and it'll also help me
prioritize which ones I want to read.
You know, also let me know which ones
you want reviews of because I'll be sure
to read those first so I can review them
for you guys. I'm reading two books at a
time, which is not something that I
typically do. I don't read I don't do
that. I'm a one book at a time girly.
I'm monogamous with my books. However,
I'm cheating. So, I'm counting these two
in my fall TBR because I'm technically
reading them right now and it is fall
sort of. So, if you're not part of my
book club, I am currently reading Inter
Mezo for my book club. The link is in my
bio. Go join, please. We have a really
great time and you can be in a Discord
and we can all chat and have fun. We
exchange our screen times every week. We
gab and we chat about things other than
books. It's a fun time, okay? And I am
absolutely loving it. If you don't know
anything about me, then you will know
that I am not a Sally Rooney stand.
Quite the opposite, actually. However,
this is turning me into one. I love this
book. So, so good. Highly recommend. And
then, because I've been in a reading
slump for the past like month, I have
been trying to think of what to read to
get me back into the habit of reading
and ignite my excitement for reading
again. And it's this one, and it's doing
it really well for me right now. Okay,
this is I was feeling epic. It's an oral
history of the Vampire Diaries. I've
watched the series from beginning to end
at least four times. It is one of my
favorite shows, even though it is not
good, but it's it is good at the same
time. You know what I mean? Um, and this
is literally just interviews with the
cast and the crew, the writers, and I'm
having a fantastic time. I read 100
pages yesterday. You can see my dog
ears. I read 100 pages yesterday, and
then I read 14, no,
50 pages this morning. And it's just so
much fun to get to know the the
backstory of my one of my favorite shows
of all time. And it's honestly getting
me really intrigued about potentially
like working in film and TV. I don't
know. Like it's really nice being able
to get kind of like a backdoor view.
What
>> that sounds weird of my favorite show
and I love it so much. Okay, so those
are the two books that I am currently
reading. But now we're going to get into
my fall TBR.
There's a lot. There's quite literally
31 books here. So, I'm going to try and
rapid fire through these. And first is
Pachinko by Minjin Lee. This is actually
our September read for my book club on
Patreon. And we're starting it on the
15th. So, if you have not picked it up
yet and you want to join my book club,
go for it. And also, you can pick it up
later in the month. We reread from the
15th to the 15th of every month. And it
follows Sunja and she is the daughter of
a fisherman who falls for a wealthy
stranger. He promises her the world, but
then she discovers that she's pregnant.
And then she also finds out that that
man is married. Tea. That's some tea.
Then she ends up marrying a like a
drifter. No. She accepts an offer of
marriage from a gentle sickly minister
passing his way through passing through
on his way to Japan. Her decision to
abandon her home and to reject her son's
powerful father sets off a dramatic saga
that will echo down through the
generations. Y'all are telling me that
this is sad and it's good, but it's
really sad and that's my kind of book.
So, and then I've been kind of missing
romance lately. So, I picked up Seven
Days in June by Tia Williams because
I've heard amazing things about this
book. I just picked it up in this vlog,
actually. This is about two black
writers who have met 15 years prior and
had like this really passionate love
affair, but then broke up, I'm assuming,
and then they meet 15 years later and
realize that both of them have been
writing each other into the books that
they're writing. Period. And Jodie Pico
said that it's smart sexy. I've been
really trying to read more diversely.
Even though I do read more diverse
Even though I do read more diversely
than a good chunk of people on the
internet, I still have way more room to
grow. And so this is part of the that's
part of the reason why I picked this one
up because romance is a very whitewashed
genre. And so I want to read romances
that are not just about white people
because white people are not the only
people that are deserving of love
stories. Okay, that's on period. Period.
No tampon. I saw someone say that on
TikTok and I've been saying it and it's
definitely like not the cutest thing to
be saying, but I like saying it, so I'm
going to keep saying it. I don't know
how I have not read this yet. It's been
on my bookshelf for a very very long
time. Like if I had to guess, it's been
on my bookshelf since June. This is I
Who have never known men by Jacqueline
Hartman. A group of 39 39 women who live
underground in a cage, but they don't
know why they're there. And then a young
girl, the 40th prisoner, sits alone and
outcast in the corner. and soon she will
show herself to be the key to the
other's escape. I've heard that the
ending to this is very polarizing, too.
So, I'm very, very excited about that. I
usually end up being on the really like
or love side of a polarizing book.
Thankfully, I haven't been spoiled yet.
And then this cover is way different
than the one that you normally see. This
is The Idiot by Alif Batumin. Batamin, I
don't know. But it just gives me like
contemporary fiction vibes where it's
about a woman that goes to Harvard and
finds herself overwhelmed with life,
which like
sure fall time for me means like college
campuses, going to school, university,
whatever it is, because I mean school
typically starts in the fall time. So I
always attribute school to fall. And so
I feel like this is perfect, especially
like Harvard. And like I've said in past
videos, I'm not the biggest fantasy
reader anymore. And so I typically lean
towards literary fiction, contemporary
fiction, romance during the fall time
because fantasy is just kind of like
bloted out for me. Like I don't really
have the desire to read fantasy anymore.
And I know a lot of people say fantasy
is like that genre for fall time. But I
disagree. Also, dark academia. But I
feel like 90% of the books that are
coming out that are labeling themselves
as dark academia are not dark academia.
Like hello publishers. Here's a note for
you. Okay. Mhm. I'm going to be nice and
gentle when I say this. Just because a
book takes place on a college campus
does not mean it is dark academia. Sad
girl vibes. I have not read this since I
was like 15. And unfortunately, this was
very formative in my current psychiatric
psyche psychiatric state. I should be in
a psych. Um, if you somehow don't know
what the bell jar is about, it is
basically about a young woman who works
at a literary magazine, right? Oh, a
fashion magazine. She basically just has
like a breakdown. That's it.
thoughtaughter literary fiction because
all the thoughts read this and also all
of the performative men read this book.
So, I'm getting both ends of the
spectrum with this one. Also, I prefer
this cover way more than the one that
you typically see. I think the that
other one is just very very ugly.
Usually, any editions by Faber and
Favor, they usually like knock it out of
the park. Love it. You're probably not
familiar with my journey with this book.
Me and this book have a sorted history.
I put this on every monthly TBR for like
eight months straight saying that I was
going to read it and then I never did. I
never followed through. I only read 150
pages of it. I think classics and the
subject matter of this book is very fall
for me. This is a retelling of Cain and
Abel from the Bible, but like not like
that, you know? basically like a family
drama and there's like kind of thriller
aspects and you like the characters are
so visceral and real feeling and there's
this one character Kathy I think is her
name right she's crazy and also fall
time is the season for me to read more
non-fiction books not a lot I can't read
a lot and so one of them is one day
everyone will have always been Against
this by Omar El Akad this is a
non-fiction piece from a award-winning
journalist he comes from a place as an
immigrant who immigrated to the west.
And this is essentially all about the
promises that western culture makes to
other countries and other cultures and
other places around the world and how we
are so incapable of following up on
those promises. Um, and he talks about
war on terror, Ferguson, climate change,
black lives matter protests, and the
slaughter in Gaza. And so I am very
intrigued to read this. And it's not too
long either. So I think it'll be a nice
quick one to stay up todate and informed
about not just Gaza and Palestine and
Israel, but a lot of other stuff that's
going on in the world and in my own
country. You know what I mean? Depressed
romance, guys, is kind of the theme
going into fall because for some reason
like summer romances to me just read so
heavily book talk vibes. Like I feel
like there's summer romances and then
there's fall romances and the summer
ones tend to be so tropeheavy and I
don't even know if this would
technically count as a romance, but it's
about love. And so I would consider a
romance that there's a lot of debate and
a lot of you guys have been clocking me
in the past and have been like,
>> um, that's not a romance because it
doesn't have a heavily
>> a heavily
>> happily ever after. And and to be
classified as a romance, it has to have
a heavily happily ever after.
>> No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. That is
the if that's the definition, that's a
stupid definition and I don't agree with
it. So, it's clearly wrong. If I don't
agree with it, it's obviously wrong.
It's about two people who were living
together and were in a very long-term
relationship and then they break up and
then they continue to share the
apartment that they had with each other.
They oscillate week over week. You know,
like for my girlies that had separated
parents where you went to go visit your
dad every other weekend. That's what
this is. They stay in the apartment
every other weekend opposite each other.
So, it's all about how they live with
like they live together but not with
each other. More depressing.
If you were to put my book taste into
like a funnel and it was to be described
as like three words. It's depressing
queer lit. That's my book taste. It's a
story about addiction, sexuality, and
love. It's a epic portrayal of a
working-class family in a queer
childhood from a masterful novelist, Mr.
Douglas Stewart. I kind of want to
reread A Little Life before I read this
one for some reason. I just feel like
it's really going to put me in the
headsp space for it, but I haven't
really taken the plunge. I have been
putting this one off. Like I think I
have had this in my collection for like
3 years. And then this one I picked up
on a whim. I have never heard of this
author before and I've never heard of
this book before. It seems very very
interesting. It's called Shelter in
Place by Alexander Maxik. I remember why
I bought this. is because it takes place
in the Pacific Northwest, which I think
is sickening because there's not enough
books that take place in the Pacific
Northwest. It is about a young man named
Joseph who is from Seattle. He starts to
suffer the symptoms of bipolar disorder
and then his mom ends up beating someone
to death with a hammer.
>> Huh.
>> And so he moves to Washington where his
mom is serving time. His mother is
gradually being transformed into a
national heroine. Many see her crime as
a furious, exasperated act of righteous
rebellion. shameless Joe and a plan that
will change their lives forever. So,
we'll see about that one. We're on book
13. Strap in. Buckle up. Put the [__]
Put the shifter Prindle.
>> Would you like M or
>> Prindle into Drive? And then once again,
more queer lit. All the world beside by
Gerard Connley. I remember what this is
about because I got this when I went to
the ESOP queer library in LA a couple
months ago. And this is a novel about a
young reverend and he lives in a
puritanical version of like 1800 1700's
New England and then a physician comes
into town and they get a little nasty. A
vividly imagined historical tale that is
both a love story and a crucible. If you
guys don't know who Gerard Connley is,
he is primarily a non-fiction writer. He
wrote Boy Erased, which is one of my
favorite memoirs and one of my favorite
movies actually of all time. And I love
the cover, too. I think the cover is so
interesting. This has also been on my
want to read for a very long time,
probably since it first came out. And
this is The Beasting by Paul Murray.
This is a family drama that follows the
Barnes family. And from what I've
gathered about people talking about it
online, it is about how someone getting
stung by a bee affects the trajectory of
their entire lives. I don't know. I'm
very intrigued by this. So, and it's
also been named the New York Times 10
best books of 2023. And then I might as
well bring this one up.
If there's one book to ever fuel my
seasonal depression more than just my
biological inability to process my own
emotions and rely on the sun to bring me
happiness, it's this. This is going to
hurt me. This is also my fifth or sixth
time reading this book and I think the
fifth or sixth time is the one that's
going to do it for me. I'm kind of tired
of having to defend this book and I'm
tired of the discourse around this book
to be honest. I'm reading it. Get over
it. And then obviously fall time. I have
to read some scarier creepy books and so
I have Monstrilio by Gerardo Salino
Cordova. This is a weird story. First of
all, it's queer
queer ally and it's about a woman whose
son dies and she takes out a piece of
his lung to like resurrect him, I'm
pretty sure. And then that lung piece
ends up growing into a sentient being.
Yeah, SJ, one of the people that I
typically get my recommendations from,
really, really liked this book. I kind
of want to make this my October book
club pick. So, if you guys feel like we
should do that, let me know. Cuz I feel
like this is the perfect October read
because I'm personally not a horror
reader. I don't like reading horror
books. I think horror books end up being
really cheesy and corny and I'm not a
thriller reader either. So, I feel like
that's the perfect mix of like literary
fiction and like a horror body horror.
And then I have on the calculation a
volume by
[__] I don't know how to say this.
Get into it, diva. I don't know how to
say that. Literary fiction book about a
woman who is reliving the same day over
and over and over again, but it talks
about like I don't even know me
describing a book.
>> It just talks about like I don't know.
>> And then I have notes. I'm reading a lot
of queer books in fall, which I love.
This is Notes on a Crocodile by Q. I'm I
will look up the names of these after
this. I'm so sorry. Um this is an NYRB
book. I've read a couple of them, but I
want to get more into them. It's about a
queer girl at a school, but it's told
through diaries, vignettes, mash notes,
apherisms, exugesis,
and satire by an incisive pro- stylist
and major countercultural figure.
Afflicted by her fatalistic attraction
to Shu Lang, an older woman, Lzi turns
for a support to a circle of friends
that includes a rich kid turned criminal
and his troubled, self-destructive gay
lover, as well as a bored, mischievous
overachiever and her alluring slacker
artist girlfriend. Damn, this is queer
as hell. And then I've been wanting to
read more dystopian books because our
world is turning into a dystopia. And by
world, I mean specifically the United
States. And so I picked up Wool. I've
had this for a while. A world that has
grown toxic. And they don't talk about
it like talk about the world is
forbidden. And so they live underground
in a single silo. There are dangerous
people, the residents who infect others
with their optimism. Their punishment is
simple. They are given the very thing
that they want. They are allowed to go
outside. After the previous sheriff
leaves the silo in a terrifying ritual,
Juliet, a mechanic from the down deep,
is suddenly and inexplicably promoted to
the head of law enforcement. With the
newfound power and with little regard
for the customs she is supposed to
abide, Juliet uncovers hints of a
sinister conspiracy. Period. That sounds
good. And there have been a lot of
dystopian books that have been coming
out that are surely not dystopian. And
so I want to read a book that is
actually a dystopian book. If one more
person and I don't care if you were
educated and went to lit English degree
school university and you are able to
fully classify that silver elite was
technically a dystopian book. It's not.
This is all the lovers in the night by
Miko Kawakami. I feel like it's very
typical Southeast Asian literature. It's
about a woman who goes on this
transformative journey of like
self-discovery. I feel like that's a lot
from Southeast Asian countries that tend
to be about that. Um, but it's about
this woman who is an editor and she's
successful, but she lives alone and it's
not easy to form new relationships in a
city, which I totally agree with. And
she ends up looking in her reflection of
a shop window and realizes that she
doesn't like who she is. And so, she
goes on a journey of like rediscovering
herself. And then I have Are You Happy?
Stories by Lorie Osteland. Are you
happy? cast a spotlight on people who
try and often fail to make peace with
their past while navigating their
present relationships and notions of
self. I'm here for that. 14 Days by
Margaret Atwood. Well, she edited this,
but it's by a bunch of different
authors. Like all of those authors down
there contributed a story or contributed
something to this book. And this is an
anthology collection about the first 14
days of the pandemic. And I think they
all take place in the same apartment
building, I think, cuz they're under
quarantine. Celeste Ing, Tommy Orange,
Diana Gabbledon, which she wrote, what's
that series called? Underlander,
Overlander, and then I have Martyr.
Yeah, I know. I know. Don't talk about
it. I know I haven't read it yet. I I'm
disgusted with myself, too. This has
been out for years, and I should have
read it already, but I haven't.
Whatever. It's about a young man
grippling with an inheritance of
violence and loss. His mother's plane
was shot down over the skies of the
Persian Gulf in a Stencil's accident.
And his father's life in America was
circumscribed by his work killing
chickens at a factory farm in the
Midwest. And the main character is a
drunk. He's a poet and I think he's an
addict, too, whose obsession with
martyrs leads him to examine the
mysteries of his past. I want to read
more um Iranian literature or books by
Iranian authors. I want to read more
books from people in the Middle East.
Like I think it is very very important
especially right now. And so I want to
read this again. I don't know how I
haven't read this yet. It literally
still has the sticker from Barnes &
Noble on it. This is apparently very
polarizing, too. Apparently, a lot of
people are like, I either loved this or
I freaking hated it. But it's a sexy,
tender, hilarious, and surprising novel
about a woman upending her life, which I
am very familiar with upending my life.
I do it on the regular. So, I feel like
I'm going to be able to relate to um
this crazy crazy lady. 30 minutes after
leaving her husband and child at home,
announcing her plan to drive cross
country, she spontaneously exits the
freeway, checks into a nondescript motel
and immerses herself in an entirely
different journey. I heard this is sexy.
Like there's a lot of like
in it. Then I have drive your bones over
the plows of the dead by Olga Takaruk.
This is a Nobel Peace Nobel Peace Prize.
No, this is the Nobel Prize in
literature winner. is a translated work
about a woman who lives in this town and
in this town people start disappearing
I'm pretty sure or people start dying.
Yeah, people start dying and bodies are
discovered and she believes that it is
related to the town's involvement of
animal cruelty. It just gives me winter
vibes and so I'm like okay fall trees. I
almost said animal cruelty. Animal
cruelty is not the vibe for fall but
like the darkness, the dreiness, the
controversial themes I feel like are
very fall. November is technically fall
for me and so November with Thanksgiving
and stuff like that, I wanted to read at
least one thing about indigenous culture
in the United States. And so I picked up
Braiding Sweetgrass. This is a
non-fiction novel. This is written by a
woman who is a citizen of the Podawatami
nation which is an indigenous tribe in
the United States. The author brings
knowledge together to show that the
awakening of a wider ecological
consciousness requires the
acknowledgement and celebration of our
reciprocal relationship with the rest of
the living world. Do I understand what
that said? No. The writer is a botonist
and she has been trained to ask
questions of nature with the tools of
science and so she relates that to
indigenous living. Robin Kimmeer shows
how the factual objective approach of
science can be enriched by the ancient
knowledge of the indigenous people. This
book is heavy, by the way. Like, it's
it's thick. Okay, we're on the last
seven, guys. And these are some of the
ones that I'm most excited about. I'm
not even gonna lie. One of them is The
Long Island Compromise by Taffy
Broadessor An Aer. And this is another
family drama kind of like The Beasting.
It is all about a man who's kidnapped
from his driveway, beaten and ransomed,
and then 40 years later, it's kind of
ruined his life and his emotional health
and how his family is also coping with
what happened 40 years prior. It says
one of the New York Times notable books
of the year. So, I have really high
hopes for that. Like 75 to 80% believe
that the New York Times has really good
taste in books on their lists. And so,
except the New York Times bestsellers
list, that is just a competition and
it's all about sales. It's not about
quality. Okay, this is the book where
she can remember how her home made her
feel, but she doesn't remember where she
lived and like who she was because this
woman is dead. It's apparently a book
that erases the line between the living
and the dead and then tells the story of
what lies underneath. Period. Cool. And
then I feel like you can't not read
Norwegian Wood in the fall. And so this
is going to be my first Murakami book
ever. Very, very nervous and excited
about it. Um, I'm one nervous because of
his portrayal of women in his stories
from what I've read about, but I'm just
going to put that aside because it is a
cultural thing, but I've heard amazing
things about this book and it's always
on people's fall TBR or recommendations
list, so I feel like it's necessary.
This is about Tou and Noo and their
mutual passion that is marked by the
tragic death of their best friend years
before. And as Naoko retreats further
into her own world, Tou finds himself
drawn to a fiercely independent and
sexually liberated young woman. Oh,
okay. I really want to read as many
Murakami books as I can because I I have
a feeling I'm going to really really
like his books, especially like Kofka on
the Shore. I've never really read
surrealist fiction, so I feel like it's
going to be a really good thing for me.
Duh duh
>> duh duh
>> duh.
You stupid [__]
>> Hello. This is a love story. It's by
Dusty. This is White Knights. Um, I have
not read this since I was again 15. It's
been a long long long long long long
time, but it explores unrequited love,
longing, and like loneliness
essentially. At its core, it's a love
story, which I love. Final three, and
they're both and they're all of them.
No, two of them are queer. Um, I have
Our Evenings by Alan Haulinghurst. This
is about a man in the 1960s who is a
person of color and goes to a white a
predominantly white school, university.
He discovers queer culture. Jack Edwards
read this in a video of his and he sold
me on it. Um, if I remember which one it
is, I'll put it right here somewhere. It
sounds amazing. He gave it nothing but
praise and I trust him for like 99% of
his book reviews. So, I have a feeling
I'm going to really, really like this
one. And I have another book on my TBR
somewhere that says that it is
reminiscent of Alan Haulinghurst, so
whatever. And it's the winner of the
Booker Prize, so it's obviously got some
redeeming qualities to it. This one I'm
very, very excited about. This is No
Names by Greg Hwitt. Two men who were in
a band and then like 15 16 something
years later, one of them is living as a
hermit on this island in the Northern
Pacific. And then he gets a letter from
a young boy who is a fan of that band
and it basically pulls him back into the
pain that he's been spending over a
decade trying to forget. It's kind of
not really fully telling me what it's
about. Ooh, that's a Oh, this makes good
slaps. Who Who else had a flip phone?
Hello. Mm- spam caller. No, thank you.
And then last, I have been talking about
this book a lot. It is Vladimir by Julia
May Jones. This is a literary fiction
novel about a woman whose husband is
being investigated for having an
inappropriate relationship with one of
his students. And then because she is
also a professor, she ends up meeting
this very, very talented young novelist
who is her student. And then she ends up
getting in a love affair with him.
You dirty lady. So that's my fall TBR,
guys. Um, do I think I'm going to get to
all of these? Probably not, but
potentially yes. But I'm feeling really
confident about these because I've
learned that if I try to build like a
very specific TBR for the season like
fall and I'm reading like cozy fantasy
and stuff, I burn myself out because
first of all, I don't like cozy fantasy
and I don't again like dark academia. I
love the classic dark academia books,
but as soon as you put a modern one in
front of me that is labeled dark
academia when it's not actually dark
academia, I just don't want anything to
do with it. thinking that the mood and
vibe of these books is giving me fall
vibes instead of it being about fall.
And remember, I want to know what's on
your fall TBR. So, I need you to leave
me some recommendations in the comments,
okay? Right down there. Remember when we
used to call it a crotch bar on old
YouTube days? Put it in my crotch. Let
me know what you're reading cuz who
knows if I get through all of these
miraculously, I'll need some more
recommendations. Okay, bye.
[Music]